[Applause]
all right hi there CNN we're here with
award-winning media contributor to ABC
News us today and the hill Don of Brazil
and former Illinois Congressman author
of renegade Adam Kissinger okay here are
the
questions that people uh any guesses on
the next candidate to drop out of the
Republican presidential primary Dan
santis yeah I think it's Dan santis he's
collapsing I think he's next what
happened there he was doing so well as a
Florida Governor he was everyone I ad
vised him publicly I said don't run
first of all no one's going to take it
from Trump you're 44 you could do this
for the next Biden next 40
years you know his problem is he was he
was he was trying to be Donald Trump his
play was Donald Trump's going to fall
out you know with the with case or
whatever and he would be there to
inherit that was a bad Play Because
Donald Trump's not going anywhere he has
no personality he's literally one of the
most boring guys I've ever worked with
and I I mean that with a straight face
terribly boring well I I think North
Dakota governor Ron Burham will drop out
I think ASA H they were still in it I
think they
did no they did oh they're well they're
not in the debate but they're not in the
debate okay but then and and and then I
also believe that Chris Christie has to
prove himself and V needs to just shut
the hell up and go home I'm
tired we all
hate okay it's it's v v
whatever would would you say that about
other I'm Donna is it V
rasama ramas Swami ramas Swami thank you
so much I learn so much when I come on
this show I know but v v v needs to go
home shut I I agree he he R I just I
just feel like there's something wrong
with everybody refusing to learn to say
his name I just feel there's a little
racism there there just a little V I'll
say it all right I'm just saying just
it's like I know we don't like him but
you know just say his name right you're
the first one I've ever heard say that I
I could be wrong maybe it's not no it is
it is it is for because I heard him do a
rap and he said it rhymes with cake okay
all right all
right this is what the CNN audience
needs to
know all right are are you surprised
that the Republican chair of the house
Ethics Committee is now pushing for
George Santos to be expelled from
Congress okay there's another one of
your did you work yeah no I'm not
surprised I mean look it's did you work
with him George Santos no thank God you
were you he came after me he came after
you but the the uh so they're down to
whatever it is three or four vote
majority now the Republican majority is
doing nothing else the rest of the year
they they'll have to deal with keeping
the government open please God they can
get Ukraine Aid done that's going to be
really important important Ukraine
Israel Etc but they're not going to do
much else so now you're at a point where
a four or a three vote majority is
pointless and he's become a huge anchor
I think even this finally crosses a red
line for them and I think they'll vote
to expel him he's an embarrassment to
the institution itself I'm a former
Congressional staffer but Bill when I
looked at that list of things he spent
campaign money on I mean all the years I
run campaign I never thought I could
just take a little drive by to Sephora
or get a little
a little Botox and a little lip he's
like the only he's the only like
campaign Finance Scandal I've ever seen
that didn't even try to launder the
money through something else he
literally just took it put it in his
bank account and got an only fans it was
like what you only fans yeah I mean
Trump wears a lot of makeup but I
assume well he does he does I mean he's
always under two PBS of
bronzer but I assum that's the Natural
Glow of somebody who's already hot he's
gone to
hell Adam as a republican who stood up
to extremists in your party what advice
do you have for Democrats who are trying
to combat the far-left okay listen this
is the best thing because I there was a
guy he was a Californian uh Dana roacher
that was like the only Pro Russian
Republican a while and people would I'd
take him on in the Foreign Affairs
committee and people would say just let
you know he's just one person
he's probably being paid by the FSB
right whatever well that crazy ends up
like overtaking The Party The Crazy of
you know nobody imagined Donald Trump in
2014 you've got to kill extremism in the
Cradle or it takes over because if you
if you look at your Coalition and say we
need this extreme we need the pro Hamas
faction or we need the you know the
anti-russia fa or the pro Russia faction
they end up calling the shots because if
everybody in this room has a grenade
right we're all equally powerful if
somebody's willing to pull the pen
they're the most powerful person in the
room and extremists are willing to pull
the pen you have got to be willing I
don't know pull the pin with them or
whatever you've got to be willing to
fight back did you ever hear that tape
of Paul Ryan Kevin McCarthy and Steve
scalise talking about uh robacker and
Trump yeah yeah okay if people don't
remember this this is the fact that this
doesn't get more play I I mean this is
years ago but this is on tape and one of
them says I think there's two people on
Putin's payroll y one of them is roarer
and one of them is Trump and the the
other two don't go oh my god let's do
something about it they say this stays
in the family right y
y
hell I tell you that's where you go it
went better in rehearsal but still
good no but it is that is kind of
amazing yeah yeah but but Bill any form
form of extremism must be denounced we
must condemn those who are Marching
saying that what Hamas did on that
horrific day was right we should
immediately call for Hamas to release
the
hostages I mean well we are we're
calling for it no but we have to demand
that you see people marching demand why
do you think Israel is attacking if they
don't just your people who are
protesting they're protesting and
they're saying leave Al and I'm might no
Hamas thought this course it's a cancer
cancer so they did a poll of the people
who live in the area from the the the
say they're saying from the river to the
sea in other words Israeli Arabs yeah
they don't want to live under Hamas n
nope that 77% of them said no thanks
we're living in Israel it's way better
than living under a terrorist group yeah
why don't you teach that at
College
um okay what do you think of prominent
Democrats like David Axelrod calling for
Biden to quote get out or get going did
he say that get out or get going uh I
believe in a tweeter too and some stuff
look people think that Joe Biden is is
is perhaps too all they right
perhaps don't don't spill the water
something might come out of it
um it's
not you know everyone ages differently I
agree I've and you know so so Betty
White live to be 99 Mick Jag is still
twisting his ass
Mr I I have been the one making that
case year after year here against agism
I always said it's a case by case basis
but but for that argument to have teeth
it all you also have to be the person
who can go yeah but this is the case and
I I've said it before do I think Joe
Biden can do the job absolutely I don't
think he can win the job and that's what
I care about he's going to lose because
the people think he's too old and
perception is reality I'm sorry he's
been cting out so many times I can't
I've just lost TR but look how many
elections since
2020 but he's won last week he was
counted out and Democrats won he was
counted out a year ago in the midterm do
not count out Joe Biden that's all I'm
saying okay but on the subject of people
getting older and they have to adjust
some tragic news this week Snoop Dog
said he's quitting po yeah I saw that
I know I posted a black Square
uh but I mean that that and I remember
him sitting right here at me telling him
this is about 10 year 12 years ago and I
said Snoop I love you and you know we're
both pot Brothers but you smoke too much
pot okay yeah because he's always on
Instagram smoking pot he doesn't even
open up his Instagram until he smoking
pot can I tell you the funniest thing
about his statement was I didn't know if
he was serious cuz at the end of it he's
like I'm giving up the smoke and he goes
please respect my privacy in this time
and I was like is really yeah I was like
did somebody die my
prediction my prediction is it'll go the
way it went when my friend woody harson
woody harlson said a number of times
he's going to give a pot and then it was
always welcome home son all right thank
you very much we'll see you next
sweet